so obviously so much has happened since
we last
last saw diana and steve in world war
one so what do you love so much about
their dynamic together in 1984.
um you know the first one
she's the fish out of water and i'm the
i'm the
the kind of the i mentor her into this
world of 1917 and
in this film it's the kind of exact
opposite and i love playing the opposite
i love playing
the fish out out of water and the guy
trying to understand what that was going
on and
um playing uh kind of an innocent
in a way you know especially um
it's a lot of fun i just you know you
don't get a chance to play that uh
at my age i guess you know yeah you also
got to rock some pretty badass fanny
packs and matching track suits that
wasn't fun
yeah playing dress-up was a good time
you know yeah uh i'm there i was there
to entertain
entertain gal
more than anything that's awesome so
when did you get the call
that steve was actually going to come
back for another wonder woman film i
mean obviously we know he dies at the
end of the first one so when did you
know you'd be back
uh sometime during the filming of the
first one
yeah patty um
had talked about my return and how that
might happen she was talking about what
the setting was and
she came up with the idea pretty quickly
so i knew a long time ago and
was just you know geared up to do it
that's awesome
um so now i have to ask do you think
this is it for yours steve trevor
i don't know morgan you got to go out
and check out the film
and see what happens and you know we'll
we'll see let's see how this one does
first
i mean at this point would it be weird
for you to
see wonder woman with a different love
interest
yeah no be angry
be jealous i love that
um you know when you're working with
someone like patty i've talked to some
of the other actors and they talk about
how much they relied on her as a
director more than you know other
projects that they've worked on
what was your relationship like with
patty she just seemed so cool
uh patty personifies the
the qualities in a good director that
you need you need to be general patton
and lead the troops and you need to be a
really sensitive
listener and observer of human nature
and and she does both
incredibly well i like her you know
spirit i like her
her animal um i like her drive i like
her
her um ability to realize her vision so
clearly and so effortless effortlessly
yeah
and um uh yeah i just love working with
her
um you know there's just so much
excitement around this film obviously
wonder woman is such an iconic superhero
but did you know
that the first film was going to connect
with audiences like the way that it did
on that
level i knew we had made a special film
when i saw it i knew
it was a really good film it was you
know sometimes you knock it out of the
park and other times you don't
um and then i remember being in new york
when we first
you know around the premiere time of the
first one and um
walking into a theater and everyone was
dressed as wonder woman
you know men fathers wives husbands kids
girls boys gays straight black white i
mean
everyone was dressed as one woman
everyone was like ecstatic and i thought
my god this is like uh
this is a really this is a very unique
experience
in that there's a um
and especially the fact that it was a
female superhero and the fact that
everybody was behind it i don't know if
i expected it but i certainly felt that
you know once we started showing it that
it was something special
that's awesome well congrats on the film
it was great talking to you you as well
thank you